- [Carolyn] To go to a cocktail party
and to see an hors d'oeuvres
that has a toothpick sticking up from it,
the point of that toothpick
makes me feel shocks of electricity
down the back of my legs.
People are perplexed by that.
My name is Carolyn Hart,
I have mirror-touch synesthesia.
Mirror-touch synesthesia is
a conflation of the senses.
The things that you see
are felt on your skin.
If I see another person's injuries,
well I feel that in my own body.
If I see someone get touched,
I feel that on my skin.
I'm a massage therapist.
I think my mirror-touch synesthesia
has really helped me.
When someone tells me
what they're feeling in their body,
well I feel it in my body.
And I think it makes me more
able to help that person.
Every single day
I will see something that
triggers waves of pain.
It makes it really hard
for me to participate
in a lot of contemporary entertainment.
Like I really love Game of Thrones
and I can't watch the program
because it's so violent.
I also have really positive experiences.
When I watch ballet I
feel my muscles fire.
When I see them executing pirouettes
I feel like I'm spinning.
And that's not an emotional sense of
"Gee, this is really lovely
and so beautiful to watch."
I feel it in my body.
I can't control it.
If I was to lose my synesthesia,
I would lose part of myself
that would be irretrievable
and irreplaceable.